[موسيقى]
وجزر الاخبار اهلا بكم عقد الرئيسان
الامريكي جوبيدا ولوكراني
صحفيا مشتركا عقب محادثاتهما في البيت
الابيض وقد كشف بيضا عن تقديم مساعدات
الاوكرانيه بقيمه مليار و850 مليون دولار
تشمل بطاريات باتريات المضاده للصواريخ
واتهم الرئيس الامريكي نظيره روسي لانه
هلاليه لديه لوقف الحرب ولا رغبه لديه في
السلامه من جانب
الصعيد روسيه في فصل الشتاء وقال ان جيشه
مستعد لمواصله القتال ببساله
اقرت وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه بان القوات
الروسيه استطاعت ان تامن لنفسها موطئه قدم
حسب تعبيرها في مدينه باخمود شرقي
اوكرانيا واضاف بيان للوزاره ان القوه
الروسيه حققت تقدما وصفاته بالبسيط في
الجهه الشرقيه من المدينه وانها تتقدم
باتجاه الاحياء السكنيه فيها وقال البيان
ان الوضع في جبهه في غايه الصعوبه
للقاضي العسكريين الروسيا بلاده موسى
تحققه جميع اهدافها العسكريه في اوكرانيا
وتحافظ على توازن الرضع النوويه الذي وصفه
بانه اساس الاستقرار في العالم
من جهته قال وزير الدفاع الروسيه وان
الجيش الروسي نشر انواعا جديده ومتطوره من
الصواريخ البحريه والبالستيه مثل منظومه
صواريخ سيركون وصارمات العابره للقارات
في بيجينا اجرى الرئيس الصيني
مع مناورات عسكريه مشتركه بين القوات
البحريه الصينيه والروسيه وقد كان الرئيس
الصيني على تطوير الشراكه مع موسكو كخيار
استراتيجيه طويل
بشراكه الاستراتيجيه بلا حدود بين البنات
قرر وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي بنجران صعدم
تسليم جثمان الشهيد الاسير ناصر ابو حميد
الى عائلته وقال انه تقرر الابقار على
جثمان رهن الحجز لضرورات نمنيه تتعلق
بمفاوضات تبادل الاسرى الاسرائيليين وكان
الاسير ناصر ابو حميد قد توفي في مستشفى
اسرائيلي نتيجه تدهور حالته الصحيه جراء
اصابته بسرطان الرئه منذ اكثر من عامه
وحملتها الاسرى حكومه الاحتلال المسؤوليه
الكامله عن وفاه ابو حميد بسبب ما وصفته
بسياسه الاهمال الطبيه بدورها رفضت عائله
ابو حميد عزاء قبل تسلمه
افاد الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني لنا شابا
فلسطينيا استشهد عقب اطلاق جنود الاحتلال
الرصاصه عليه وعدد اخر من الشبان في الحي
الشرقي لمدينه نابلس واكدت مصادر طبيه من
خمسه شبان اخرين قد اصيبوا بالرصاص
الحقيقي خلال محاوله التصدي لجنود
الاحتلال
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]